this is catch-and-release sorry no Rob
this time I he heard his back and on top
of that he has company coming in so he's
very busy bee and a very in pain beef
whatever that means
so yeah just gonna be me this time uh
and yeah this is an episode that very
much kind of a lot happens and little
happens um they find paradigm rather
paradise canet Steven to get the
transporter working he can't fix it so
they come they capture her and Steven
thinks that she has more to reveal so he
releases her and it turns out she's not
very big she's about the size of Steven
um would have been a little funnier if
she if peridot was like if the body was
even bigger I mean I get it she's about
the size of the other gems but it's like
if she was really big now would have
been a lot funnier but yeah the limbs
and stuff those are just artificial it's
not a part of her uh so uh Steven
releases her she likes slapping him
obviously he's not used to more human
form and just having kind of a weak body
and stuff so she runs away into the
bathroom walks herself in there is kind
of very childish and the gems know that
she has some information that they need
and so they decide to just leave her in
there and they don't know exactly what
they're gonna do but they know they need
to get information out of her um and it
just servants there it ends with Steven
forming a little bit of a relationship
like he's being nicer to her and stuff
but yeah there's not really much else on
top of that sort of Ed's right in the
middle of this so it's pretty obvious
you can't do an episode like this
without it continuing into the next one
uh so I'm kind of curious to see the
next one it's it's hard to talk about
cuz I haven't seen the next one and it's
you know they're all kind of to be
continues and continuing a story but
this one was so right in the middle like
it so didn't have it ending it just sort
of stopped in the middle of this
predicament uh so but for a predicament
it's funny
um and it's uh it's you know the word
Steven uses is
so cute and it it is it's a very cute
setup for someone that's a supervillain
and try to kill them several times um
and peridot kaya has a I don't know she
might if pearl was a villain that's kind
of what I get out of her um and she just
gets funnier and funnier the more I see
her and it's just I think the fact that
she is so tiny now in the way she moves
uh before was grave could she had the
artificial limbs and the fingers that
could go everywhere and I love how they
would form arrows when she needed to
point down um and all sorts of cool
stuff but now that she's this human form
a she's moving kind of like a chameleon
and climbing the walls and stuff but
still getting used to having a human
form so uh it's very very funny and adds
a lot of character to her as well and I
like this set up I like the idea that
she's just gonna be stuck in this
bathroom which she keeps asking if
everything's a weapon um and just
doesn't understand the world that she's
in so it's a good set up I was see where
it's gonna go it's hard to comment on it
uh because it is just obviously a setup
but um yeah peridot is becoming kind of
one of my favorite characters here she
just it's another one of those classic
nothing goes right for the villain
characters you know it's kinda like
being in the brain or dark helmet or
even nostalgia critic in some of the
anniversary special so um I love those
characters I love those villains that
try to look very intimidating but just
nothing quite falls into place uh so
it's a good character it's a good setup
I like that
cuz in the opening you know she's trying
to say something and the gems you know
bubble her up and they say huh well
that's just the talk of a gem that's
trying to get out of trouble or
something and I was thinking about
something I've seen this a lot you know
and haven't I figured out can listening
to Steven a lot of stuff is usually
right and usually the lesson of the
episode and I like that they kind of
come around they come around pretty
quick but still reluctantly cuz they
have to just keep her in the bathroom um
now she's stuck in the bathroom but yeah
it's just one of those things where I'm
they come around at the end of GLAAD
it's something where they say okay we
let's do this let's listen to Stephen it
doesn't take a couple episodes to come
around or anything they do it rather
quickly because I think if they just
agree to it would be a little strange
and out of character and I think the way
they have it does a lot more of a
connection between her and Stephen which
I think could be a very funny connection
cuz he's just so humble and so nice and
so welcoming and she's obviously trying
to be this super villain and you know
sometimes it's very good at most of the
times is not uh so yeah try to think
what else um you know the expressions on
peridot I really love it the expressions
all of them are always so good but yeah
the the reactions from her and
everything they are just so extreme in
the long faces and the eyes get big and
then small on the same thing with the
mouth and everything so I love those
expressions are so much her there it
just adds to the character a lot and the
only other thing I noticed on this one
that I thought was kind of enjoyable was
something about amethyst acting in this
one the voice actor is like it was
especially funny there is something it's
really really humorous about her
delivery on it um and I has anyone
anywhere made a gift yet of just peridot
going go round and round in the toilet
cuz I think that would be very very
funny uh if not get on that Internet I'm
sure you have all right you probably
have like five different versions upside
downside whatever but uh yeah I think
that's about it uh I thought was a
really fun episode I'm like I said I'm
anxious to find out what's gonna happen
the next one cuz it's obviously it to be
continued um and I'm curious to see
worth it's gonna go but excited cuz I
love peridot I want to see more with her
so we will see more with her later bye
bye